ariane a fait construire une belle
terrasse en bois
mais l'été suivant tout s'écroule
furieuse du travail parler de la
compagnie elle veut faire rembourser
mais découvre que l'entreprise n'existe
plus l'unique propriétaire a pris sa
retraite et à fermer son entreprise
il n'a pas fait faillite il a dissout sa
société alors ariane peut-elle
poursuivre une compagnie 10 août
oui mais elle doit agir vite au plus
tard dans les trois ans de la
dissolution si l'entreprise est
incorporé au québec ou dans les deux ans
si l'entreprise est incorporé sous le
régime fédéral il faut envoyer ces
procédures à l'ancien administrateur et
si on gagne sa cause
le ou les actionnaires devront payer la
note jusqu'à concurrence de ce qu'ils
ont reçues au moment de fermer boutique
le fin mot de l'histoire lorsqu'une
compagnie ferme ses portes
il vous reste une fenêtre pour faire
valoir vos droits